georges savez bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin dans
la matinale de rtl france pour commencer
peut-être qu'elle est très concrètement
la situation aujourd'hui des populations
en syrie où on a si peu d'image assez
peu de retours finalement qu'est ce que
vous vivez vous aujourd'hui concrètement
avant tout bon jour à tout le monde
il fallait à ce moment c'est c'est
glacial
nous manquons d'électricité nous avons
une électricité très rationner nous
avons à peu près 2 par jour de
l'électricité ne manquant aussi de fioul
donc on n'a pas de quoi nous chauffer la
population souffre de tout cela vous
pouvez imaginer par exemple que il y a
des gens qui mettent des tissus dans des
poêles pour se chauffer ou bien qu'ils
n'ont rien absolument rien pour se
chauffer en ce temps glacial
nous manquons aussi d'essence il y à des
villes très longue de voitures qui
attendent leur tour parfois c'est deux
ou trois jours qui sont dans la file
pour recevoir la même quantité près
rationner d'essence pour pouvoir
conduire leur voiture
la situation est assez dramatique à alep
puisque j'y suis et à laquelle je
voudrais témoigner
c'est une situation où la population est
en train de souffrir réellement de ces
sanctions
nous subissons et nous avons besoin nous
avons besoin que ces sanctions soient
levées à l'est est une ville qui n'a pas
été reconstruite
nous sommes en 2021 halep a été libéré
le 16 décembre 2016 et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et hull les traces la ruine
l'héroïne la destruction la l'incapacité
de reprendre la vie économie et la haine
elle avait normal nous a incité à lancer
secret pour lever les sanctions contre
la population syrienne
alep est toute la syrie à travers mon
appel la population syrienne a besoin de
ne pas rester à mendier son droit à la
vie son droit à être compte toutes les
populations du monde dans la dignité
nous ne voulons pas être les mendiants
de l'aide humanitaire qui viennent des
grands organismes
nous voulons vivre dignement notre vie
on se
en cette année 20 21
c'est pourquoi oui georges s'habille en
plus de ce que vous décrivez il ya aussi
la crise sanitaire j'imagine qu'ils
doivent compliquer les choses
voilà je voulais arriver aussi à la
crise sanitaire pour vous dire que comme
tous les pays du monde
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans la crise
due qu'aux vives 19 donc les
l'hospitalisation tous les appareils
respiratoires
tout ce que nous pouvons avoir dans
notre au service de la santé manquent et
et manque terriblement à la population
c'est vrai qu'en europe aux etats unis
ou ailleurs
il y a aussi le co vide mais quand vous
avez les moyens c'est c'est bon mais
nous manquons de moyens et ça c'est je
crois encore un appel nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui la possibilité de survivre
du point de vue sanitaire les des
médicaments qui manquent
l'assistance médicale dans les hôpitaux
mais aussi et tout cela a des
conséquences sur la vie
quotidienne des gens le coc vide 19 les
gens je dois vous dire je sais pas si si
ils peuvent encore supporter plus que ce
que ils ont reçu porté depuis 2012 je
parle d'alep aux biens 2011 depuis là
pour la syrie nous avons suivi la guerre
nous avons subies actuellement nous
sommes en train de subir aussi une crise
économique très forte
et en plus il y a le convive 19
je crois que les gens en ont assez ils
sont terriblement terriblement affecté
par tout ce qui est en train de tout ce
qu'ils sont en train de vivre
alors c'est de là que les sanctions
georges savez justement quel type dess
vous demandez aujourd'hui pour que cette
situation cesse en syrie vous savez ce
que nous demandons c'est qu'on nous
rende notre dignité de personne humaine
lever les sanctions s'il vous plaît
lever les sanctions
nous avons le devoir de vivre en tant
que population nous avons le droit
d'être comme tout le monde ça c'est la
meilleure des des déserts que vous
pouvez nous apporter vous pouvez nous
apporter peut-être n'importe quelle aide
mais n'oubliez pas que la syrie a été
pour l'entente par exemple grenier du
moyen-orient même de rendre depuis le
temps de de l'époque de l'empiré au
maine
nous ne pouvons pas être aujourd'hui des
mendiants nous ne pouvons pas être des
mendiants nous voulons notre dignité
savez sur la situation sécuritaire est
ce que ça aussi ça ça s'améliore ou pas
d'une façon générale dans la ville
d'alep elle-même la situation
sécuritaire s'est très
améliorer mais je dois parler aussi qu'
il y a des résurgences de temps en temps
actuellement du côté de la route qui
conduit vers le centre de la ville il ya
il a eu quelques attaques de
groupuscules dedans et il y a le
nord-est de la syrie du côté de deir
ezzor où il ya encore plein d' attaque
il ya eu une attaque israélienne
il y à la fin il ya deux jours une
attaque une autre attaque israélienne
donc nous sommes en train aussi de vivre
une certaine menace sécuritaire la plus
grave actuellement c'est la menace
disons vital pour pouvoir vivre et
survivre
normalement merci beaucoup georges saab
et pour votre témoignage ce matin dans
la matinale de france je le rappelle
vous êtes frères maristes bleus à alep
merci à vous